bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hace 10 años la organización
nacionalista eta puso fin a sus acciones
terroristas está decidido declarar un
alto el fuego permanente y de carácter
general que puede ser verificado por la
comunidad internacional
este es el compromiso firme de eta con
un proceso de solución definitivo y con
el final de la confrontación armada
aunque esta banda del país vasco se
disolvió por completo en 2018 tras 60
años de existencia fue el 20 de octubre
de 2011 cuando cesó por completo la
violencia que tanto atormentó a españa y
a francia eta es una sigla que traducida
del idioma euskera significa país vasco
y libertad también fue el nombre
escogido en la década de 1950 por un
grupo de jóvenes nacionalistas vascos
cuyo objetivo era la creación de un
estado socialista en la región euskal
herria que por siglos han habitado los
vascos entre el norte de españa y el sur
de francia
se trata de uno de los problemas
separatistas más antiguos del mundo ya
que el movimiento independentista vasco
existe desde hace siglos tanto así que
durante la guerra civil española se creó
una república vasca la cual fue
aplastada por el general francisco
franco quien además ordenó en tiempos de
su dictadura que cualquier otro signo de
emancipación fuera severamente asfixiado
por madrid' pero de ser una organización
clandestina de oposición eta cruzó la
línea hacia ser una organización
terrorista el 2 de agosto de 1968 con el
asesinato de melitón manzanas
el asesinato del comisario manzanas no
fue un hecho aislado símbolo de la
represión franquista su muerte marcó el
inicio de una guerra abierta entre eta y
madrid un año más tarde la policía acusó
al militante de eta disco de la iglesia
como el autor intelectual del crimen
pese a que éste siempre lo negó también
puso en cintura judicial a otros
militantes acusados de secuestro y
terrorismo en un juicio que cautivó la
atención de toda europa el denominado
proceso de burgos
la resolución del juicio era la pena de
muerte para seis de estos militantes de
eta pero era tal la presión
internacional sobre el régimen de franco
que en lugar de ejecutarlos fueron
indultados así que inflamado de
popularidad eta volvió a dar un golpe en
1973 esta vez contra el propio corazón
de la política española el objetivo fue
la mano derecha de franco el para
entonces presidente del gobierno español
luis carrero blanco la forma de matarlo
fue explotar su vehículo volando lo en
pedazos por el centro de madrid hecho en
el que también murieron su
guardaespaldas y conductor la frialdad y
premeditación de eta habían quedado
claras eta se ganaba la simpatía de los
sectores más extremos de la izquierda
pero quedaba maltrecha ante la opinión
pública por el desprecio que demostraba
contra los derechos humanos el dictador
franco murió en
1975 y con el rey juan carlos como
sucesor españa entró en un camino hacia
la democratización que selló finalmente
el presidente del gobierno adolfo suárez
entretanto el gobierno español creó los
gal grupos antiterroristas de liberación
en síntesis agentes españoles
encubiertos que perseguían a los
nacionalistas vascos sin importar que
fuera en territorio francés y cuyas
acciones fueron calificadas por la
prensa como la guerra sucia contra eta
pese a la lucha armada en nombre del
independentismo vasco la reputación de
eta estaba por los suelos luego de
perpetrar atentados como el de la bomba
que explotó en un centro comercial de
barcelona en 1987 y que dejó 21 muertos
o el secuestro de josé antonio ortega
lara un funcionario de prisiones que
duró más de 530 días cautivo entre el 96
y el 97 pero un asesinato en específico
fue la gota que colmó el vaso en julio
de 1997 eta secuestró al concejal
español por el pp miguel ángel blanco a
cambio pidieron al gobierno de josé
maría aznar la reubicación de los presos
de eta en las cárceles del país vasco
quienes por entonces estaban dispersados
en otras cárceles de españa' para evitar
su concentración
ante la negativa de aznar eta asesinó a
sangre fría al concejal de inmediato
está ahí un sentimiento ciudadano de
repulsión contra eta' miles de personas
salieron a las calles en diferentes
ciudades del país vasco para expresar su
rechazo en un capítulo conocido como el
espíritu de ermua en honor al
levantamiento social en la ciudad natal
del concejal blanco empezando el siglo
21 las dos grandes corrientes políticas
de españa el partido popular y el
partido socialista lograron ilegalizar
mediante una ley de 2002 el
funcionamiento del brazo político de
eta- herri batasuna además el mundo
había cambiado después de los atentados
del 11 de septiembre de 2001 en eeuu y
cuando ocurrieron los ataques del 11 de
marzo de 2004 en los trenes de cercanías
de madrid por el que murieron 193
personas y más de 2.000 resultaron
heridas las autoridades pensaron que
ésta había sido responsable y que sobre
su organización se vendría todo el peso
conjunto de europa pero dicho atentado
el peor en la historia de españa' 4
tiempo después a células de al qaeda y
del grupo islámico marroquí sin embargo
eta no se quedaría de brazos cruzados y
volvió a atacar en 2006 con una bomba en
la terminal 4 del aeropuerto barajas de
madrid en la que murieron dos
ecuatorianos tras este atentado y los
repetitivos incumplimientos de cese del
fuego la cooperación policial entre
francia y españa acelera un proceso para
desmantelar el aparato financiero de eta
y empujarlos a la desaparición de esta
manera y tras varios años de decadencia
el 20 de octubre de 2011 eta decidió por
sí mismo poner punto final al terror y a
las hostilidades con que asoló a españa
durante décadas siete años después
disolvió por completo su organización
sin haber logrado el cometido de la
independencia del país vasco así
terminamos soy andrés varias jaramillo
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]